at a camp outside taiwan's Capital
civilians hone their shooting skills
this is more than a gun club as tensions
have spiked between Beijing and Taipei
people here say they're preparing to
defend their Homeland
I think doing uh this training will help
for when we are against China threat I
can ensure our well very clearly that we
are not going to surrender these are
private premises people are choosing and
paying to do this but it goes where the
political narrative calling for
reinforced civil defense even when it
comes to more regular forms of emergency
training many have a particular kind of
emergency in mind well this has to do
with taiwan's situation Taiwan is this
is a country that is prone to lots of
natural disasters and of course an
adversary that is intent on using force
on us so all the preparation we're doing
here is to prepare us in peace time and
potentially in Wartime in December the
U.S Congress authorized 10 billion
dollars in military aid for Taiwan
running until 2027 citing what it called
a coordinated Chinese campaign to weaken
Taiwan diplomatically economically and
militarily
China views Taiwan as part of its
territory and says its policy remains
one of reunification reserving the right
to use Force if necessary it criticizes
what it calls American collusion with
Taipei something Beijing says was
exacerbated by then house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi's visit to Taiwan last year
taiwan's Western kinman Island is just
two kilometers from the Chinese Mainland
aging Beach defenses stand in memory to
a famous victory over Communist forces
here in 1949 but some fear the capacity
to mount such a defense now is lacking
if China invades Taiwan even in the
presence of the US and Western countries
support it will be a daunting task to
fight off in the absence of foreign
support it's only a matter of time
before China takes over the island
last month a leaked Memo from a U.S
four-star general predicted a Chinese
invasion of Taiwan and a U.S China
conflict in 2025. it was criticized as
irresponsible by some warmongering by
others many in Taiwan will hope it was
just plain wrong Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera